高低という用語
は、日本のピッチ アクセント研究では常に出てきます
が、もちろん実際には、
話者が感情や意図に
基づいてトーンを大幅に変更する可能性があるのは、2 つのトーンだけではありません
。
コミュニケーションをとっていて、これについて多くの質問を受ける
人々はよく言う
単語の高低アクセント
がこれであるはずであることは理解していますが
、少し違うことを聞いてい
ます 今ここで何が起こっているのか 私は
これを詳細に分析します patreon の私の
日本語音声シリーズのレッスン 6.3
約 20 分のレッスンですが
、そのレッスンの 7 分ほどのチャンクがあり
、多くの人が見るのに非常に役立つと思う
ので、
今日は YouTube で共有したいと思います。 ビデオ
の最後でいくつかコメントを共有します
が、今のところはすぐに始めましょう
皆さん、こんにちは。道元
による日本語の音声学のエピソード 6.3 へようこそ。
このレッスンでは、バイナリ g について話します。
このシリーズのグラフとスペクトログラフで
は、単語のピッチ アクセント パターンを表示するときにバイナリ グラフィックを使用
します。つまり、
このシリーズ全体で使用する標準的なグラフィックでは
、高低の 2 つのトーンのみを表示します
これは通常の慣行であり、基本的にすべての
日本語の音声リソースはバイナリを使用します
ピッチアクセントを示す
グラフィックス このようなグラフィックスを使用する
人もいれば、このようなグラフィックスを使用する人もいれば、
このようなグラフィックスを使用する人もいます これらすべてのグラフィックス
は
、単語にアクセントがあるかどうかに関係なく、基本的に1つのもののみを表示することを意図し
ています。 その単語
はアクセントが発生する
ため、たとえば、この単語 Japan のバイナリ グラフィックは、その単語の
2 番目のモーラにアクセントがあることを示していますが
、特定の話者がその
単語をどのように発声し、その声の感情と意図をその単語にマッピングしたかを示しているわけではありません
このようなことを考えるのに役立つかもしれません。dictionary.com で
アメリカという言葉を調べる
と、言葉の定義と
この発音キーは、この発音キーのマーレ セクションが
太字になっていることがわかります。これは、アクセントが単語のこの音節にあることを示すためのもの
です。もちろん、
アメリカにはさまざまな正しい言い方が
あります。 アメリカのように幸せな方法で
言うこと
も、アメリカのように怒って言うことも
、アメリカのように質問として言うこともできるので、
何を言おうとしているか
、単語だけでなく単語の発音を強調するかによって異なります。
ピッチは少し変わりますが、
一般的に言えば変わらないことで
あり、これは特に
1 つの単語のフレーズに当てはまります。
アメリカでも、
アメリカでも、アメリカでも、アクセントの位置は再び変わります。アクセントは Met のままです。
形を作り、
言葉を発して感情や意図
をそれにマッピングするとき、私たちは
その形を少し伸ばして遊んでいます.今では、
dictionary.comや他の辞書は
明らかに分光器や
コンピュータを表示することはできません. アメリカという単語の受け入れ可能なすべての発音に対してter生成されたピッチ波
な
ので、代わりにこれを
もう一度表示します アクセントがどこにあるかを示すキー
辞書は単語の
基本的な形を示し、次に言語
学習者は、話者が実際に言うときを知ってこの形を学び
ます
日本語の高低
訛り図はこれに似ています この
図表はアクセントと日本語がどこに
あるかを示しています ネイティブ
スピーカーがこの単語をゆっくりと慎重に言うと、次の
ようになります
次に、この録音のスペクトログラフを作成しました。これはこれ
とかなり似ているかもしれません。
実際、その録音のスペクトログラフを見てみましょう。
非常に近いですが、
話者は私を家にいると言うことが
できますが、日本や日本などと言うことができます
が、 繰り返しますが、
ピッチ アクセントのリソース
が、Japan という単語の許容されるすべての発音のスペクトログラフをリストすることは不可能であるため、
代わりにピッチ アクセントのリソースでは bi を使用します。
単語の
基本的な特性、つまり高低
アクセント リソースを示す nary Graphics は、バイナリ グラフィックスを使用して
、単語にアクセントがあるかどうかを示します。
スピーカー
はこれらの形で伸びて遊んでいます。そのため
、私たちが聞くもの
が、このシリーズや他のピッチ アクセント リソースで使用されている種類
のグラフィックスと常に完全に一致するとは限りません。 私のシリーズや他のピッチ アクセントのリソースで使用され
ているグラフィックスと常に完全に一致するとは限り
ません。多くの場合、人々
はこれについて私
に
尋ねることになります。 単語のトーンと実際のピッチ アクション パターンに影響を与える可能性のある
個々および地域の方言の方言の
バリエーションがいくつか
あり
ますが、私の経験ではほとんどの場合
あなたが聞いていることが
単語のピッチオックスパターンと一致していないとき、
それは話者が
自分の感情や意図を
単語にイントネーションを与えている単語にマッピングし
ているためです。
ストレッチして言葉を
いじる ピッチ アクセント パターン
さて、ビデオに戻ります 多くの
人が 2 つのことを疑問に思っていると思います。
話者が自分の感情
と意図をどのようにマッピングするかによって異なります.
ピッチアクセントを研究するポイントは何ですか.私
はこれらの質問の両方に答えたいと
思います.
特に
私の経験上、日本語をしばらく勉強している場合は、
おそらくすでに自然な方法でこれを行って
い
ます 自分の感情や意図
を言葉にマッピングする 彼らは通常、その方法を明確に学んだり研究したことがなくても
、幸せ、悲しみ、怒り、または
疑問を抱く方法で言葉を言う
方法
を知っ
ています。 シリーズですが、
ほとんどの人は自然にこれが得意な
ので、しばらく日本語を勉強
していて、多くのことを日本語に没頭しているなら、
おそらくすでに
感情や意図
を多かれ少なかれ自然な方法で言葉にマッピングしているでしょう。
ただし、これは、言いたいことに
応じて単語の形を伸ばして遊ぶ方法を自然
に知っている場合でも、
最初から間違った形で伸ばし
て遊んでいる場合は、大きな警告です。 つまり、日本語と日本語と日本語は
大丈夫ですが
、
日本語
と
はすべて間違っています。言い換えれば
、感情と意図を単語にマッピングし、
正しく聞こえるようにするのは比較的簡単です。 その単語の基本的な特性を知っているので、
ピッチ アクセントを研究し
ます。実際に話し、
自分の感情や意図を
単語にマッピングするときに、正しい
ピッチ アクセントのパターンや形を使用して学習するように、ピッチ アクセントを研究
します。 バイナリ ピッチはこのように作用し、グラフィックス
は無意識のうちに
これ
とこれを
言うことができます。では
、ピッチ アクセントを研究することが重要である理由と、
ピッチ アクセント リソース
がスペクトログラフではなくバイナリ グラフィックスを使用し
てピッチ アクセントを教えている理由を学びましたが、そこにはありますか? スペクトログラフ
から学べる有用な情報
はあり
ます。今日のレッスンの残りの部分で
は、これらのトピックの 1 つについて話します。そこで
、ピッチ牛のイントネーション
と、聞こえる音が常に完全に一致するとは限らない理由を見ていきます。
画面に表示されているものと、
これは
20 分間のレッスン全体からの 7 分間ほどのサンプル クリップであり、
私がピッチ I の微妙な低下と呼んでいる現象もカバーしています。
それが何であるか、また、ほとんどの学習者がそれにどのように取り組む
べきだと私が考えるかを分析し
ます。
これについて詳しく知りたい場合は
、ここからアクセスできる完全なレッスンをチェックすることをお勧めします。
日本語の高低アクセントの基本の種類の詳細については、こちらの YouTube
で無料で利用できるレッスンがあります。
基本だけを超えたい人は、ここで
再びリンクされている私の完全な patreon シリーズをチェックすることをお勧めします。
以下の説明で、
ご支援いただきありがとう
ございます。今後の日本語学習の成功を祈っています。